تمثل القوات الأوكرانية في استعادة
مدينة ليمون مكسبًا مهمًا للغاية
منذ هجومها المضاد
في الشهر الماضي فقط ، فماذا يعني انتصار اليوم
لبقية الحرب ، دعونا
نجلب محلل زينا العسكري الكولونيل سيدريك
لايتون للانضمام إلينا الآن هناك في
الجدار السحري حسنًا ، لذا الكولونيل ، كيف يمكن
لاستعادة أوكرانيا لليمون
تعزيز موقعهم في
ساحات القتال
الأكبر
جيدًا
؟  تقع مباشرة على
أعتاب الحدود بين المناطق المختلفة
التي لديك هنا منطقة لوهانسك
ومنطقة دونيتسك ، وكلاهما
جزء من منطقة دونبوس وهذه
الحقيقة بالذات تجعل هذه نقطة رئيسية وقد ذكر
وزير الدفاع أوستن أن
هذا هو  منطقة إستراتيجية رئيسية
لأنها مركز مواصلات ،
وحقيقة أنها مركز مواصلات من
خلال هذه المنطقة تعني
أنها شديدة الصعوبة  من المهم بالنسبة لجهود إعادة الإمداد الروسية
في هذه المناطق هنا
وكذلك بالنسبة للأوكرانيين ، لذا فإن
حقيقة أن الأوكرانيين قد
استولوا الآن على ليمون هي بالفعل أكبر
شيء قاموا به في
الشمال الشرقي وقد يكون
ذلك كثيرًا جدًا  مغير اللعبة ووفقًا
لتحليل CNN للبيانات الحصرية
من معهد دراسة الحرب بعد سبعة
أشهر من هذا الغزو ، فإن روسيا
تسيطر على مساحة أقل مما كانت عليه في
الأيام الأولى من الحرب ، أعني
أن هذا أمر لا يصدق إلى حد كبير ، ما الذي
يخبرك ذلك جيدًا.  مهم حقًا
لأنه يُظهر باميلا أن هناك
الكثير مما
فعله الروس والذي لم يتحقق شيئًا لم
يكن الروس يسيطرون على
المناطق طوال الطريق من هنا هذه
المنطقة من هنا بالطبع
كل هذا  لقد سيطروا على كل هذه
المناطق المختلفة وحقيقة
أن الخريطة تبدو هكذا اليوم مع
السيطرة الأوكرانية هنا في وقت سابق من
الحرب.  شمال كييف
التي تقع هنا واستعادت
كل هذه المناطق وحقيقة
أنهم كانوا يحرزون بعض التقدم في
الجنوب يعني أن الأوكرانيين
يحرزون حقًا الكثير من التقدم في هذه
المنطقة ولديهم زخم إلى
جانبهم  وهذا شيء مهم حقًا عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالحرب وفي زخم الحرب هذا
هو كل شيء